democracy democracy democracy democracy
democracy is not what these people need
hell it's not even what they want
democracy democracy call of duty
advanced warfare trailer just came out
hi folks I'm Chris waters joined by eric
tay here to talk about the leak about
the trailer and about what we're gonna
see in call of duty advanced warfare
starting with democracy the guy who says
that Kevin Spacey yep they Kevin Spacey
man like it's I think everyone on their
way it was going crazy yes like that's
the draw yes well I'm people were
psyched about Kevin Spacey I mean he's a
great actor obviously like drawing a lot
of attention recently for house of cards
and in this you know in that one he
plays sort of this manipulator on the
political scene and here we sort of see
his role right they can do another
extreme he's now the head of this pmc
private military corporation and is sort
of meddling in the Foreign Affairs of
countries who he doesn't believe are
ready for democracy ah it's nice to have
a villain but call of duty has had some
good villains in the past us but I'm
thinking specifically of the guy from
black ops 2 row Raul Melendez yeah it
was like really nasty so will be
interesting to see if Kevin Spacey goes
real nasty or like how that progresses
um but you know obviously it still in
terms of setting this is another globe
trotter you're gonna be fighting on the
Golden Gate Bridge and you're gonna be
in these countries Oh far afield what
where do you think you're gonna end up
and this I don't even know I mean it's
it's weird like like you said we did see
the Golden Gate Bridge just typical I
guess um but you can go anywhere really
I mean like there's all these countries
that aren't ready for democracy right
maybe we're gonna have to go there and
you think that you can just march into
these countries based on some
fundamentalist religious
principles drop a few bombs topple a
dictator and started amok recy let's
talk multiplayer then cuz there are a
bunch of gadgets that we saw in the
trailer as starting with the different
degrees of suits so run us through what
we got going down the line so it kind of
seems like there's like you know like
the man and the Machine mixed together
you know you kind of got that Elysium
feel and then you kind of have like an
armored version of that like where it's
just like kind of covers the soldier
kind of like GI Joe ish in a way more
heavy dude yeah and then you have your
like third tier which is like kind of
like a mech with a big chain Gatling gun
on it yeah not giant dude and like
either that thing would like in case him
entirely and like you not be very mobile
but does that Bigfoot buh buh buh buh
buh buh I so like the thing that
obviously these they look slick like the
design of Call of Duty sort of
futuristic stuff always really neat but
what about the abilities jumping sort of
that power jump we see that a lot so
that's obviously in fact they're hugely
into gameplay abilities like that stuff
that like would you know you would
imagine operate on a cool-down like you
can do that jump I mean what's to stop
you from doing that a bunch in combat uh
you know this kind of stuff coming in to
call of duty do you see the series
taking influence taking a sort of a
departure from the you know a further
departure from the modern warfare routes
and getting more fantastical I mean
maybe I mean it's hard like because we
don't know all the perks systems and
what not yet but we we know that there's
an emphasis on the exoskeleton suits and
like how that's going to be volved a
game so it's going to be interesting to
see how cloak works in call of duty and
then the Superdome but like you said
it's probably cool down based so you
can't just spam it um but it would be
interesting to see what players do
tactically with these new abilities I
guess but again it's kind of like kind
of folly so we'll see yeah well which
one are you interested in personally
like which one would you pick you got I
think I think cloak probably they don't
I don't know if the super jump
necessarily I mean like unless maybe I'm
just like yeah maybe capture the flash
maybe it's good for that oh I'm thing
like that so maybe you know abilities
for different modes but hopefully the
spice is it up I don't know alright well
let's move on to vehicles we've got a
bunch they show
off in the trailer as well number one I
think the coolest when we saw hoverbikes
nair hoverbikes yeah what do you I I
mean all right is this just another like
snowmobile sequence it's gonna be you
know very linear during the campaign and
you're not gonna see it at all in the
multiplayer or do you think they're
gonna like it a little bit more give us
a little more leeway with vehicles um I
mean it'll be interesting to see there
hasn't been too many usage of like
actually like driving or like
controlling the vehicles in previous
Call of Duty's I think the last one we
may have saw was maybe black ops 2 or a
multi-player yeah I multiplayer I think
you'll definitely see it in single
player of course like I think a lot of
the vehicles you see in the trailer
you'll you'll see in single player it'll
be interesting to see if they actually
implement that in the multiplayer to
maybe change things up maybe you get
that hover bike sooner and then maybe
you know you have to deal with it now if
you will have that though you need the
maps to be much bigger I mean if you're
talking about having pilot able vehicles
in their proper they aren't just perks
that sort of come in once and exist like
the helicopter sort of outside of the
map you're talking about fundamentally
changing the design and you know
certainly broadening the kind of space
that you cover getting into almost some
battlefield territory do you think they
would they would try to sniff that out a
little bit I mean I I think I feel like
with ghosts right like they started to
get maps that were bigger than your
normal call of duty maps now there
weren't very many and I think they had
those probably for specific map types
yeah but I mean I wouldn't be surprised
that they tried a little bit i mean like
even battlefield tried to call a duty
right with close quarter combat air
groover at some point you're gonna have
to innovate past what call of duty does
I mean as long as it still plays like
Call of Duty I think having the map be a
little bit bigger it's fine um but we'll
see and if you've got these you know the
power suit stick and maybe make you run
faster jump farther you can cover that
distance more feasibly if you're on foot
then maybe you've got some parity there
that allows the hoverbikes to make it in
ah what about walking thank you see the
tank just like yeah I'm on tech tread
now I'm up on my tank legs now I'm
shooting laser beams at enemies like uh
is that just sort of it hey what do you
think want to tag with leg I don't know
I find it hard to believe that that's
gonna be a multi that'll be pretty
serious yeah sweet single player
because like it's usually I called you
to six on six usually right so i don't
know maybe ground warfare yeah you know
you would need some serious anti-vehicle
weaponry if you're bringing that thing
in the multi player so I think it's safe
to say that'll be a single player the
single player domain only may be some
kind of like spec ops or like a co-op
mission my thing but what about that
directed energy weapon though oh yeah
shooting like blue lasers maybe are you
kills bad or let overhead yabber bike
sorry yeah maybe yeah it's fun to
speculate about all this stuff of course
and we want you guys to speculate with
us obviously the trailers been out for a
couple hours now not even a full day but
speculation is running rampant please
join us in the comments below sound off
on what you think you saw in that
trailer what you want to see what you're
hoping for from advanced warfare and let
us know democracy democracy America's
been trying to install democracies and
nations for a century and it hasn't
worked one time